[Musique]
cela fait seulement quelques mois que
ses élèves répètent leurs chorégraphies
se placer dans ces chanter et jouer tout
cela à la fois mais à les entendre ce
n'est pas si compliqué faut bien
articuler déjà et chantier assez fort et
se mettre dans le personnage
j'aime bien danser j'aime bien chanter
et c'est rigolo de faire ça parfois
c'est facile parfois c'est difficile
faut se dire qu'à personnes qui nous
regardent dans la salle mêlant tous les
arts la comédie musicale est un genre
théâtral apparu au début du 20e siècle
des créations comme louise où errent
dans les années 60-70 ont favorisé sa
popularité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
créé par sharon qui rejoint les années
90 cela fait trois ans que cette école
s'est installé à la royale factory de
versailles une affaire de famille
ses fils donne les cours de théâtre et
de chant on a une semaine de théâtre
ensuite une semaine de chant ensuite une
semaine de théâtre aussi surtout au
début ce que le théâtre c'est très
important pour la libération de l'esprit
et la tranquillité et il ya une semaine
à la fin de chorégraphies chanter où on
travaille le théâtre le chant et la
danse en même temps ce que j'attends de
mes élèves c'est
la liberté en fait j'ai j'aspire à les
amener à une certaine liberté
d'expression je travaille beaucoup sur
l'improvisation l'imagination je compare
temps en temps pendant l'année avec des
textes je leur donne des textes à
apprendre par coeur pour comparer qu'est
ce que c'est l'improvisation qu'est ce
que c'est de travail sur texte qu est la
différence entre chaque personnage
résultats de ces mois d'enseignement sur
scène parmi les pièces déjà présenté au
public grise
annie et oliver quelques places sont
encore disponibles pour rejoindre la
troupe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]